Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Jake: 来露亚开始了吗
Jake: Lucia, have you started?
Jake: 啊好好
Jake: Ah, okay, okay.
Jake: 那我们后边先看
Jake: Let's watch from the back first.
Alice:耶
Alice: Yay!
Lucia: 啊开始了
Lucia: Ah, it's started.
Shure: 应该快一
Shure: It should be almost one.
Alice: 看这个好茂盛
Alice: Look, this is so lush.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Tasha: 他真好
Tasha: He's really nice.
Jake: 好我们有很多东西
Jake: Alright, we have a lot of stuff.
Jake: 稍等一下
Jake: Hold on a sec.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Alice: 这是别人那啥的
Alice: This is someone else's stuff.
Jake:唉
Jake: Sigh.
Jake: 你可以走那边,其实
Jake: You can go that way, actually.
Alice: 东西没落车上吗
Alice: Didn't you leave the stuff in the car?
Katrina:  哇这个更
Katrina: Wow, this is even...
Katrina:  这个有点重我拿不了
Katrina: This is a bit heavy, I can't carry it.
Lucia: 我们俩一起
Lucia: Let's do it together.
Lucia: 哇这个真的好重
Lucia: Wow, this is really heavy.
Lucia: 对，咱俩一起
Lucia: Yeah, let's do it together.
Lucia: 要不可能里面饮料比较多
Lucia: Maybe there are a lot of drinks inside.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, yes.
Jake: 我来吧
Jake: I'll do it.
Jake: 喔，这怎么这个样子
Jake: Whoa, why is it like this?
Lucia: 这个，还能拿动吗，这个撒了
Lucia: Can we still lift it? It's spilled.
Lucia: 可以把这个这个 我手拿着
Lucia: We can take this, I'll hold it.
Tasha: 眼睛头疼不疼
Tasha: Does your head hurt?
Tasha: 小心点啊
Tasha: Be careful.
Tasha: 他他的摄像头
Tasha: His camera.
Jake: 我我我头疼
Jake: My head hurts.
Jake: 哎呀头确实疼
Jake: Oh man, my head really hurts.
Jake:还有
Jake: And...
Alice: 还有
Alice: And...
Alice: 还有我们的司机  跟蒜苗
Alice: And our driver and the garlic sprouts.
Tasha: 我我
Tasha: Me, me.
Jake: 好谢谢谢谢你
Jake: Alright, thank you, thank you.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 没没没掉吧
Lucia: No, no, it didn't fall, right?
Tasha: 哎蒜
Tasha: Hey, garlic
Alice: 哎呀这个不是我们的吧
Alice: Oh no, this isn't ours, right?
Tasha: 不是都不是了
Tasha: No, none of it is
Alice: 哦走吧OK
Alice: Oh, let's go, OK
Lucia: 哇这个真的好重
Lucia: Wow, this is really heavy
Katrina:  我拿走了
Katrina: I'll take it
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh dear
Tasha: 怎么开商务座的都要打领带
Tasha: Why do all the business class people have to wear ties?
Tasha: 穿皮裤啊
Tasha: And leather pants?
Tasha: 哦不，穿，穿西装裤
Tasha: Oh no, I mean, suit pants
Jake: 不知道哎
Jake: I don't know
Alice: 我觉得这两个花也可以
Alice: I think these two flowers are nice too
Alice: 你看挺好看的
Alice: Look, they are quite pretty
Tasha: 是的嘞
Tasha: Yes, indeed
Alice:他把我这个偷
Alice: He stole mine
Jake:嗯哼哎哎呦
Jake: Uh-huh, oh dear
Alice: 呃拿花
Alice: Uh, take the flowers
Katrina:  我刚刚搜了一下
Katrina: I just searched for it
Alice:给记录下来了   是的
Alice: Got it recorded, yes
Katrina:  也是的海报他很多淘宝上都是发的
Katrina: Yeah, many of those posters on Taobao are just like that
Katrina: 就是那种网图
Katrina: Just internet pictures
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Katrina:  那咱自己打印也行
Katrina: We could print them ourselves
Jake:也可以
Jake: That works too
Tasha: 呃前面一个吧
Tasha: Uh, the one in front
Tasha: 这个像那棵树的那个地方
Tasha: The one that looks like that tree over there
Jake: 哦给
Jake: Oh, here you go
Alice:你这个小花装起来好好看啊
Alice: Your little flower arrangement looks so pretty
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah, yeah
Jake:额
Jake: Uh
Jake: 这个像
Jake: This looks like
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Tasha: 很多
Tasha: A lot
Jake:认不得家了
Jake: Can't recognize home anymore
Jake: 世界地球是啥啥啥
Jake: What is World Earth something something?
Jake: 忘了啊
Jake: Forgot it
Katrina:  就是那个海报
Katrina: It's that poster
Katrina:  我搜到的都是网盘
Katrina: All I found were cloud drives.
Katrina:  就是那种虚拟的
Katrina: Like those virtual ones.
Katrina:  那就是自己打印呗
Katrina: So, we should just print it ourselves?
Jake: 哦哦哦OK啊
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, OK.
Jake: 可以啊你
Jake: Sure, you can do it.
Alice: 们的房子不是绿色的吗
Alice: Isn't our house green?
Tasha: 蓝色
Tasha: Blue.
Tasha: 蓝绿色
Tasha: Blue-green.
Alice:这个吗
Alice: This one?
Alice: 这个颜色吗
Alice: This color?
Jake:就是这个
Jake: Yes, this one.
Tasha: 前面这个
Tasha: The one in front.
Tasha: 但感觉又走错了
Tasha: But it feels like we're lost.
Alice: 你们不应该是从那个吗
Alice: Shouldn't you have come from there?
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Jake: 对和昨天一样
Jake: Yeah, same as yesterday.
Lucia: 这个这个这个
Lucia: This one, this one, this one.
Jake: 里边水比较重是吧
Jake: The water inside is quite heavy, right?
Lucia: 对就是哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, it is, haha.
Lucia: 我得稍微放一下调整一下我的手
Lucia: I need to put it down and adjust my hand a bit.
Jake:要不我们
Jake: How about we...
Jake: 要不我们极限一换一
Jake: How about we do a one-for-one swap?
Jake: 我们极限一换一
Jake: Let's do a one-for-one swap.
Lucia: 哎你一只手提这个
Lucia: Hey, can you carry this with one hand?
Jake: 我试一下我试一下我试一下
Jake: Let me try, let me try, let me try.
Lucia: 不重吗
Lucia: Isn't it heavy?
Lucia: 会不会太重了
Lucia: Isn't it too heavy?
Jake: 好奇一下这个有多重
Jake: Just curious how heavy this is.
Lucia: 真的真的很重
Lucia: It's really, really heavy.
Tasha: 你健身吗
Tasha: Do you work out?
Jake:哎哎哦 哎呦不好意思
Jake: Oh, oh, sorry.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Watch out.
Jake:撞撞到你头了是吧
Jake: Did I bump your head?
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 咱俩都在头疼一下了
Lucia: We both got a little headache.
Jake:额哈哈不
Jake: Haha, no.
Lucia: 是吧这个有点
Lucia: Right, this is kind of...
Tasha: 你现在声音
Tasha: Your voice now...
Lucia: 要不你把这个袋子给我们俩
Lucia: How about you give us this bag?
Jake:不是不是这个
Jake: No, not this one.
Jake: 你你你
Jake: You you you
Lucia: 能提动那个吗
Lucia: Can you move that?
Jake: 你可能
Jake: You might
Jake: 你可能觉得这个好像比这个更重
Jake: You might think this seems heavier than that
Lucia: 是这样吗
Lucia: Is that so?
Lucia: 这个好像也挺重的
Lucia: This seems pretty heavy too
Alice:额啊
Alice: Uh huh
Lucia: 是的但好像比刚那个稍微好一点点
Lucia: Yeah, but it seems a bit better than the last one
Jake: OK行
Jake: OK, sure
Lucia: 我们加快步伐
Lucia: Let's speed up
Jake: 极限一换一
Jake: Extreme one-for-one
Alice: 这个给我吧
Alice: Give this to me
Lucia: 谢谢您辛苦了
Lucia: Thank you, you worked hard
Jake:额呵没有
Jake: Uh, no problem
Jake: 健身我是两年前健
Jake: I started working out two years ago
Jake: 我到新加坡之后就不健了
Jake: I stopped after I moved to Singapore
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because
Jake:你有
Jake: You have
Alice:右右右
Alice: Right, right, right
Jake: 右边右边啊
Jake: To the right, to the right
Lucia: 因为工作比较忙嘛
Lucia: Because work is pretty busy, right?
Jake: 因为健身房有点远啊
Jake: Because the gym is a bit far
Jake: 就是作为一个p人吧
Jake: As a person
Jake: 就健身房他不在楼底下我应该很难去
Jake: If the gym isn't downstairs, it's hard for me to go
Lucia: 是这样的是这样的哈哈
Lucia: That's true, that's true, haha
Lucia: 任何东西不离我很近我一般都很难去
Lucia: Anything that's not close by is hard for me to go to
Jake: 在这个里边
Jake: In here
Tasha: 应该把小米装
Tasha: Should put the Xiaomi
Tasha: 装小米烤箱的那个袋子带着的
Tasha: Put it in the bag for the Xiaomi oven
Jake: 什么袋子
Jake: What bag?
Tasha: 那个大袋子啊
Tasha: That big bag
Jake: 小米烤箱
Jake: The Xiaomi oven
Jake:额ok
Jake: Uh, okay
Jake: 还有个线是吧
Jake: There's also a cord, right?
Alice: 那个小狗那
Alice: The little dog
Alice: 他作作作
Alice: He's he's he's
Alice: 他就他就过来看你
Alice: He comes over to see you
Katrina:  然后今天不喂他烤肉呢
Katrina: And today we're not feeding him barbeque?
Alice: 这个啧啧啧
Alice: This, tsk tsk tsk
Alice: 像他喝奶的声音
Alice: Sounds like he's drinking milk.
Alice: 东西我换一个
Alice: Let me change it.
Alice: 行
Alice: Okay.
Lucia: 我们的有有密码吗
Lucia: Does ours have a password?
Jake: 有密码但是我记不住
Jake: Yeah, but I can't remember it.
Lucia: 嗯哈哈
Lucia: Hmm, haha.
Lucia: 那您来说
Lucia: Then you say it.
Jake: 我要查一下手机
Jake: I need to check my phone.
Jake: 这个时候手机如果能告诉我
Jake: If only my phone could tell me now.
Tasha: 但我记住了
Tasha: But I remember it.
Tasha: 不是这么说的吗
Tasha: Isn't that what you said?
Lucia: 问一下星瑞
Lucia: Ask Xingrui.
Jake: 哦但他说的好像是但他记住了
Jake: Oh, but he said he remembers it.
Lucia: 啊这个好像是
Lucia: Ah, that seems right.
Jake: 哈哈我没有记住
Jake: Haha, I didn't remember it.
Lucia: 这个要是有语音功能就好了
Lucia: It would be great if it had a voice feature.
Lucia: 对问问他
Lucia: Yeah, ask him.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 我发现这个摄像头会发出彩虹光哎
Lucia: I noticed this camera emits a rainbow light.
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake: 再再再摁一次那个3
Jake: Press the 3 again.
Jake: 那个3再摁一下
Lucia: 那我我
Lucia: Then I...
Jake:三三
Jake: Three, three.
Lucia: 怎样能把它删掉
Lucia: How can I delete it?
Jake: 不就不用
Jake: No need to.
Jake: 不用重来
Jake: No need to restart.
Jake: 就就是你直接重来就行
Jake: Just start over directly.
Jake: 他就算最后一位
Jake: It counts as the last digit.
Lucia: 925
Lucia: 925.
Jake:对是
Jake: Yes, it is.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 我们一块来吧
Lucia: Let's do it together.
Lucia: 这真的太重了
Lucia: This is really heavy.
Jake: 就就我们就这什么呀到底
Jake: So, what is this exactly?
Alice: 这是他的帽子
Alice: It's his hat.
Lucia: 哎这个怎么
Lucia: How does this...
Jake: 我们就把这个密码大声的输出来
Jake: Let's input the password loudly.
Jake: 这真的合适
Jake: Is this really suitable?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake: 你怕这个邻居听不见是吧
Jake: Are you afraid the neighbors can't hear this?
Jake: 嗯大家好
Jake: Hmm, hello everyone
Jake: 我们的门禁是
Jake: Our door code is
Tasha: 往里面放一点
Tasha: Put it a bit more inside
Tasha: 哇这个真的来放不了了
Tasha: Wow, we really can't fit this in
Katrina:  真的很离谱
Katrina: This is really absurd
Lucia: 真的很赛博
Lucia: It's really cyberpunk
Lucia: 您的卧室真的很赛博
Lucia: Your bedroom is really cyberpunk
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake: 晚上就是这个样子
Jake: It's like this at night
Jake: 因为怕这个关掉之后数据就倒不过去
Jake: Because I'm afraid if I turn it off, the data won't transfer
Jake: 对得开着
Jake: So it has to stay on
Jake: 然后突然惊醒的看一眼哦
Jake: Then I suddenly wake up, check it, and oh
Jake: 还在传哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: It's still transferring, hahaha
Lucia: 我可以在你的小桌子上玩2077吗
Lucia: Can I play 2077 on your small table?
Lucia: 哈哈沉浸式玩游戏
Lucia: Haha, immersive gaming
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha
Jake: 是呵
Jake: Yeah
Katrina:  我要记一下我们还有什么东西没买
Katrina: I need to note down what else we need to buy
Katrina:  笔呢
Katrina: Where's the pen?
Tasha: 我们先把要放进冰箱的挑出来
Tasha: Let's first pick out what needs to go in the fridge
Tasha: 把
Tasha: Put
Katrina:  这个笔呢
Katrina: Where's the pen?
Katrina:  谁看见了
Katrina: Has anyone seen it?
Jake: 笔我带上去了我
Jake: I took the pen upstairs
Jake: 再带下来
Jake: I'll bring it back down
Lucia: 我想喝口水
Lucia: I want a drink of water
Katrina:  没有没开的水
Katrina: We don't have any unopened water
Lucia: 呦这这对
Lucia: Oh, this, this
Lucia: 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Lucia: Dun dun dun dun dun dun
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Tasha: 咦是吧
Tasha: Eh, right?
Lucia: 什么情况啊
Lucia: What's going on?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This
Jake: 要不砍了吧
Jake: Should we cut it?
Lucia: 对他好像打不开
Lucia: Yeah, it seems it can't be opened
Jake: 买一个大刀把它给剪了
Jake: Buy a big knife and cut it.
Lucia: 哦开了开了
Lucia: Oh, it's open now.
Lucia: 有点紧那个
Lucia: It's a bit tight.
Lucia: 记得
Lucia: Remember.
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Tasha: 水果水果放一起
Tasha: Fruits, put the fruits together.
Tasha: 蔬菜放一起对
Tasha: Put the vegetables together, right.
Lucia: 没开封的饮料其实可以先放在外面
Lucia: Unopened drinks can actually be left outside first.
Jake: 头在哪
Jake: Where's the head?
Lucia: 是咱们现在因为东西比较多就不要
Lucia: Because we have a lot of stuff now, let's not...
Alice: 楼上是不是还有冰箱
Alice: Is there a fridge upstairs?
Katrina:  那我把对饮料放楼上去
Katrina: I'll take the drinks upstairs then.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:对楼上也有冰箱
Jake: Yes, there's a fridge upstairs too.
Lucia: 楼上有个冰箱
Lucia: There's a fridge upstairs.
Jake: 等一下先先别
Jake: Wait, wait, don't...
Lucia: 先把先把先把必须放冰箱的放进去
Lucia: Let's put the things that must go in the fridge first.
Jake:先把冰给放一下
Jake: Let's put the ice in first.
Lucia: 然后再考虑别的
Lucia: Then we can think about other stuff.
Lucia: 冰
Lucia: Ice.
Jake:就是要放冰冻的
Jake: We need to put the frozen stuff in.
Jake: 冷冻的哦
Jake: Frozen stuff, okay.
Katrina:  还有个蓝莓是吗
Katrina: There's also some blueberries, right?
Katrina:  冷冻啊这个是需要放冰箱的
Katrina: This needs to go in the freezer.
Tasha: 还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: There's a box of strawberries too.
Tasha: 啊哦在这
Tasha: Oh, here it is.
Tasha: 哦吓我一跳
Tasha: Oh, it scared me.
Katrina:  这个是必须放冰箱的
Katrina: This needs to go in the fridge.
Lucia: 这个是放冷藏室
Lucia: This goes in the fridge.
Lucia: 冷冻室
Lucia: The freezer.
Katrina: 冷藏吧
Katrina: The fridge.
Katrina:  冷冻冷藏
Katrina: The freezer, the fridge.
Alice:冷藏
Alice: The fridge.
Alice: 冻冻这个冷藏有0度吗
Alice: Does the fridge have a zero-degree compartment?
Alice: 我怎么感觉这温度不太够
Alice: I feel like it's not cold enough.
Katrina:  我把饮料挤入哎
Katrina: I'll squeeze the drinks in.
Jake: 哎你们不是有那个测温的吗
Jake: Don't you guys have a thermometer?
Jake: 呵没有用吗
Jake: Doesn't it work?
Tasha: 要要干嘛
Tasha: What do you want to do?
Jake: 测冰箱多少度
Jake: Check the temperature of the fridge.
Lucia: 万一不够的话
Lucia: In case it's not enough
Lucia: 那个肉也可以放冷冻室
Lucia: You can put the meat in the freezer
Lucia: 然后尽快吃
Lucia: And eat it as soon as possible
Lucia: 只要它上面结的霜不要太多就行
Lucia: As long as there's not too much frost on it
Tasha: 这放两瓶鲜牛奶刚刚好
Tasha: This fits two bottles of fresh milk perfectly
Tasha: 这个可以拿出来了
Tasha: We can take this one out
Alice: 鲜牛奶
Alice: Fresh milk
Katrina: 这
Katrina: This
Katrina:  这这个扔了吧
Katrina: Let's throw this away
Tasha: 这个可以拿出来
Tasha: We can take this one out
Katrina:  烤鸭这个昨天晚上
Katrina: The roast duck from last night
Tasha: 我天哪冰箱里面放菜说我不能接受
Tasha: Oh my gosh, I can't accept putting food in the fridge without covering it
Katrina:  而且没有盖保鲜膜
Katrina: And there's no cling film
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed
Katrina:  扔了吧
Katrina: Let's just throw it away
Jake: 丢吧来
Jake: Yeah, throw it out
Katrina:  这酒啥的我放二楼吧
Katrina: I'll put the wine and stuff on the second floor
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay
Katrina:  我想这一楼先做饭是在一楼吧
Katrina: I think we should cook on the first floor for now
Katrina:  可是这样的
Katrina: But like this
Lucia: 蛋要放冰箱吧应该
Lucia: Shouldn't the eggs go in the fridge?
Lucia: 芒果
Lucia: Mangoes
Jake:芒果
Jake: Mangoes
Lucia: 芒果是用来做做甜品的时候用的吗
Lucia: Are the mangoes for making desserts?
Jake: 呃好
Jake: Uh, okay
Jake: 是吗芒果是给人
Jake: Are the mangoes for people to eat or...
Jake: 吃的还是
Jake: ...what?
Lucia: 对我也想
Lucia: Yeah, I was wondering
Tasha: 额做甜品的
Tasha: Uh, for making desserts
Jake:做甜品
Jake: For making desserts
Lucia: 那这个呢
Lucia: What about this?
Jake: 那为什么要6个呀
Jake: Why are there six of them?
Tasha: 我只是觉得6个比较划算
Tasha: I just thought six was a good deal
Jake: 哦我以为你数了6个人呢
Jake: Oh, I thought you counted six people
Lucia: 一人一个
Lucia: One for each person
Jake: 对哈哈哈
Jake: Right, haha
Lucia: 呃今晚就把它吃掉
Lucia: Let's just eat them tonight
Jake:你说的特别的
Jake: You sound very...
Lucia: 那这个这个
Lucia: And this, this
Jake:和你说的75这个数字
Jake: And you mentioned the number 75
Lucia: 这个菠萝是今天晚上吃的
Lucia: Is this pineapple for tonight?
Lucia: 还是要用的
Lucia: Or are we going to use it?
Tasha: 呃今天晚上吃的啊
Tasha: Uh, it's for tonight, right?
Lucia: 那要不就放外面
Lucia: Then maybe leave it outside.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 反正今天晚上要吃
Lucia: Anyway, we’re eating it tonight.
Jake: 我们点个外卖吧
Jake: Let's order takeout.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Sure.
Jake:给给
Jake: Here you go.
Tasha: 还有一瓶鲜奶呢
Tasha: There's still a bottle of fresh milk.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Alice:还需要
Alice: Do we still need...
Alice: 还有肉吗
Alice: any more meat?
Tasha: 没有肉了啊
Tasha: No more meat.
Katrina:  还有虾滑
Katrina: There’s still shrimp paste.
Katrina:  等一下还还有一瓶虾滑
Katrina: Wait, there's another bottle of shrimp paste.
Katrina:  放哪里啊
Katrina: Where should I put it?
Katrina:  我来
Katrina: I'll do it.
Tasha: 还有一瓶鲜奶呢
Tasha: There's still a bottle of fresh milk.
Lucia: 嗯啊西瓜
Lucia: Yeah, and watermelon.
Tasha: 牛奶
Tasha: And milk.
Alice: 就是怎么只剩一个了
Alice: Why is there only one left?
Tasha: 哎怎么只剩一瓶牛奶了啊
Tasha: Hey, why is there only one bottle of milk left?
Lucia: 那那里那里那里还有一个袋子
Lucia: There, there, there’s another bag.
Jake:放进去了
Jake: I put it in.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 我来拿吧
Lucia: I'll take it.
Tasha: 你
Tasha: You...
Jake:错了错了错了
Jake: Wrong, wrong, wrong.
Jake: 对不起对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Tasha: 放这的
Tasha: Put it here.
Tasha: 因为感觉这样子一定要放在一起
Tasha: Because it looks better when put together.
Tasha: 就会很好看
Tasha: It looks really nice.
Tasha: 对所以我一直在找他
Tasha: That's why I've been looking for it.
Alice:蛋是不是放这
Alice: Should the eggs go here?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Yeah, right.
Alice:这有个蛋篓
Alice: There's an egg basket.
Lucia: 这里还有一盒蛋
Lucia: There’s another box of eggs here.
Tasha: 这盒蛋是可食用蛋
Tasha: These eggs are edible.
Tasha: 可生吃蛋
Tasha: You can eat raw eggs.
Alice: 这个
Alice: This one?
Tasha: 直接这样吧
Tasha: Just like this.
Alice: 哇哦
Alice: Wow.
Tasha: 还可以嗯
Tasha: It's okay, yeah.
Alice: 这底下我觉得可以利用一下
Alice: I think we can use the bottom part.
Tasha: 可以先放这
Tasha: We can put it here first.
Jake:哎你
Jake: Hey, you...
Jake: 你们在采购之前
Jake: Before you guys went shopping,
Jake: 有人仔细的看过冰箱吗
Jake: Did anyone carefully check the fridge?
Katrina:  没有咋啦
Katrina: No, why?
Lucia: 但是需要的话
Lucia: But if we need to,
Lucia: 咱们可以现在上仔细的看一下
Lucia: We can go check it carefully now.
Lucia: 那个没用了的冰箱
Lucia: The fridge that's not being used.
Lucia: 还没用到的冰箱啊
Lucia: The one that's not been used yet.
Jake: 额也不用也不用
Jake: Uh, no need, no need.
Jake: 就是就就
Jake: It's just that...
Jake: 你们其实也没有看冰箱
Jake: You guys didn't actually check the fridge.
Jake: 大概也就知道怎么回事了是吗
Jake: So you roughly know what's going on, right?
Lucia: 呃怎么回事
Lucia: Uh, what's going on?
Jake:就是就是
Jake: It's just that...
Jake: 就是大概
Jake: It's just roughly...
Jake: 呃我们装多少东西啊
Jake: Uh, how much stuff we can store.
Lucia: 哦这个能放吗
Lucia: Oh, can this fit?
Tasha: 有一个估算吧
Tasha: We have a rough estimate.
Jake: 可能有吧
Jake: Maybe we do.
Jake: 就当有吧
Jake: Let's just assume we do.
Jake: 问题不大
Jake: It's not a big problem.
Lucia: 我们可以姑且认为他有
Lucia: We can roughly assume we do.
Jake: 对对对就
Jake: Yeah, yeah, just...
Lucia: 这还有两盒安佳稀奶油和这个
Lucia: There are two more boxes of Anchor cream and this.
Lucia: 这个也要放冰箱吧
Lucia: This also needs to go in the fridge, right?
Alice: 嗯可以可以
Alice: Yeah, it can, it can.
Tasha: 这些奶油都放这吧
Tasha: Let's put all this cream here.
Tasha: 已经塞不下了
Tasha: It's already full.
Alice: 你搁这吧
Alice: Put it here.
Tasha: 啊可是他应该放在那个区域
Tasha: But it should go in that area.
Alice: 没事
Alice: No worries.
Tasha: 但奶油有三瓶哎
Tasha: But there are three bottles of cream.
Katrina:  三瓶吗这里面怎么感觉
Katrina: Three bottles? How come it feels like...
Lucia: 哦哦还有一瓶耶
Lucia: Oh oh, there's another bottle!
Alice: 把它放这
Alice: Put it here.
Tasha: 什么还有蓝莓啊
Tasha: What? There's still blueberries?
Lucia: 这个先在这放一下吧
Lucia: Let's put this here for now.
Lucia: 如果不是今天晚上吃的就放到冰箱
Lucia: If we're not eating this tonight, put it in the fridge.
Jake: 吃什么呢
Jake: What are we eating?
Jake: 晚上吃什么呢
Jake: What are we eating tonight?
Lucia: 晚上吃什么呢
Lucia: What are we eating tonight?
Jake: 吃什么呢
Jake: What are we eating?
Jake: 烧烤哈哈
Jake: BBQ, haha.
Tasha: 一定要记进去
Tasha: We must write it down.
Jake:饭呢
Jake: What about rice?
Tasha: 好就这样记
Tasha: Okay, just write it down like that.
Jake: 盖浇饭
Jake: Rice with toppings.
Jake: 吉野家板面
Jake: Yoshinoya noodles.
Jake: 三文鱼
Jake: Salmon.
Lucia: 都可以
Lucia: All are fine.
Jake:烤全鱼
Jake: Grilled whole fish.
Jake: 螺蛳粉
Jake: Snail noodles.
Lucia: 螺蛳粉咱们这个房间透气性好吗
Lucia: Is the ventilation in this room good for snail noodles?
Jake: 那确实不太好
Jake: It's really not that good.
Jake: 蟹黄拌饭
Jake: Crab roe mixed rice.
Jake: 肉蟹堡
Jake: Crab burger.
Jake: 春饼
Jake: Spring pancakes.
Tasha: 还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: There's still a box of strawberries.
Lucia: 呃是不是在那里面
Lucia: Uh, is it in there?
Lucia: 没有吗
Lucia: No?
Lucia: 哎那那边那个也已经拿出来了
Lucia: Oh, that one over there has already been taken out.
Jake: 火锅底料
Jake: Hot pot base.
Lucia: 倒是还有一盒蓝莓不过
Lucia: There's still a box of blueberries though.
Tasha: 蓝莓放在这
Tasha: Put the blueberries here.
Tasha: 我嗯还还有一盒草莓呢
Tasha: I, um, still have a box of strawberries.
Katrina:  这只有一盒
Katrina: There's only one box.
Katrina: 喏，那里
Katrina: Look, there.
Lucia: 噢
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 天呐就跟瞎了一样
Tasha: Gosh, it's like I'm blind.
Katrina:  是的是的哎
Katrina: Yes, yes, indeed.
Jake: 哎我们把这个灯开下来
Jake: Hey, let's turn on this light.
Jake: 可能就少瞎一点
Jake: Maybe we'll be a bit less blind.
Lucia: 哦厨房还有个灯
Lucia: Oh, there's another light in the kitchen.
Jake: 对在这边少瞎一点
Jake: Yeah, put it here and don't mess around.
Lucia: great
Lucia: Great.
Tasha: 这都是调味料了
Tasha: These are all seasonings.
Alice: 调味料哎
Alice: Seasonings, huh?
Tasha: 柠檬和这个
Tasha: Lemon and this.
Alice: 下面可以放
Alice: You can put it below.
Lucia: 这个要不要拆一下
Lucia: Should we unpack this?
Lucia: 然后放这个冰箱
Lucia: And then put it in the fridge.
Tasha:  这个蔬菜
Tasha: These vegetables.
Lucia: 蔬菜也放冰箱吗
Lucia: Do the veggies go in the fridge too?
Lucia: 今天晚上又不吃
Lucia: We’re not eating them tonight anyway.
Tasha: 还有这个
Tasha: And this too.
Tasha: 他真是一个煞风景的东西
Tasha: This is really a mood killer.
Jake:谁
Jake: What?
Tasha: 它
Tasha: It.
Jake:哦 这个
Jake: Oh, this.
Alice: 放常温也可以啊
Alice: It can stay at room temperature too.
Jake:这不用放冰箱吧
Jake: No need to refrigerate this, right?
Tasha: 放冰箱
Jake: 对啊放外边当武器挂门上
Jake: Yeah, hang it outside as a weapon.
Tasha: 这个是不是也是常温就可以
Tasha: This can stay at room temperature too, right?
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 这个我们拿的时候是常温的
Lucia: It was at room temperature when we got it.
Jake:对啊放外边
Jake: Yeah, leave it outside.
Lucia: 你看那个密封的
Lucia: Look, it's sealed.
Jake:放外边放哪呢
Jake: Where should we leave it outside?
Katrina:  扔个垃圾
Katrina: Just throw it away.
Lucia: 哎这不是垃圾桶吗
Lucia: Hey, isn't this the trash can?
Jake: 是垃圾桶
Jake: It is a trash can.
Jake: 但是 哎
Jake: But, hey...
Lucia: 他他他
Lucia: He, he, he...
Alice:那个内胆
Alice: The inner liner.
Jake:哦哦哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Alice:用来醒花了
Alice: It's used for holding flowers.
Jake: 就这个已经被改装了
Jake: This has already been modified.
Tasha: 改良了
Tasha: Improved.
Jake:给你看
Jake: Look.
Jake: 改良成那个样子
Jake: Modified like that.
Jake: 哎改良完了
Jake: It's all done.
Katrina: 我把饮料都放二楼了
Katrina: I put all the drinks upstairs.
Lucia: 是这样的吗
Lucia: Is that so?
Jake: 改完了是吧
Jake: Done changing it, right?
Alice: 用过了
Alice: Used it already.
Jake:哦他们原来
Jake: Oh, they originally...
Jake: 他们原来把这个当作
Jake: They originally used this...
Jake: 这个装花的容器啊
Jake: As a flower container.
Lucia: 哦 ok
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Katrina:  我洗过了一点
Katrina: I washed it a bit.
Jake: 哎哎哎哎哎哎哎  呃OK
Jake: Hey hey hey hey, uh, okay.
Jake: 现在有啊
Jake: Now we have it.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Katrina: 干啥来着
Katrina: What were we doing again?
Lucia: 这这个魔芋丝和这些
Lucia: These konjac strips and these...
Lucia: 这些是不是也是放冰箱的
Lucia: Should these also go in the fridge?
Alice: 是的是的
Alice: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 这个葱姜蒜组合放外面就行了
Tasha: The scallion, ginger, and garlic combo can be left outside.
Lucia: 对葱姜蒜可以放外面
Lucia: Right, scallion, ginger, and garlic can be left outside.
Lucia: 里面嗯
Lucia: Inside, hmm...
Lucia: 土豆呢还有这个糕点吗那是
Lucia: What about potatoes and these pastries?
Lucia: 两个葱姜蒜组合
Lucia: Two scallion, ginger, and garlic combos.
Tasha: 怕一个不够啊
Tasha: Afraid one won't be enough.
Lucia: 还有海盐
Lucia: Also, sea salt.
Lucia: 摇摇奶盖嗯
Lucia: Shake it up with milk foam, hmm.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 红薯应该是常温就可以吧
Lucia: Sweet potatoes should be okay at room temperature, right?
Lucia: 这个菜要不要放冰箱
Lucia: Should these vegetables go in the fridge?
Lucia: 这个今天晚上要用吗
Lucia: Are we using them tonight?
Alice: 不用
Alice: No.
露丝：那就放冰箱
Lucia: Then put them in the fridge.
Tasha: 这可乐不适合放在这里了已经
Tasha: This cola shouldn't be kept here anymore.
Lucia: 这个我觉得这个袋子里剩下的东西
Lucia: I think the things left in this bag...
Lucia: 应该都是放常温就行
Lucia: Should all be fine at room temperature.
Lucia: 大家可以检查一下
Lucia: Everyone can check.
Tasha: 午餐肉放进去吧
Tasha: Let's put the luncheon meat in the fridge.
Lucia: ok
Lucia: Okay.
Jake: 哎我把这个倒掉
Jake: Hey, I'll pour this out.
Jake: 呃弄一个小垃圾袋吧
Jake: Uh, let's use a small trash bag.
Alice: 我换个鞋
Alice: I'll change my shoes.
Tasha: 那就拿这个不就行了吗
Tasha: Just use this one, won't that work?
Jake: 这个太大了
Jake: This one is too big.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 这是这些也是火锅的
Tasha: These are for the hotpot too.
Lucia: 刚那个火锅底料在哪放着呢
Lucia: Where did we put the hotpot base just now?
Tasha: 这呢这这都是调味料
Tasha: Here, these are all seasonings.
Tasha: 这个袋子里的
Tasha: In this bag.
Lucia: 那就把这个
Lucia: Then put this here.
Alice:火锅底料在这呢
Alice: The hotpot base is here.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 那要不把那个火锅底料也放到这里面
Lucia: How about we put the hotpot base in here too?
Lucia: 然后这个
Lucia: And then this...
Lucia: 这个红薯跟这些东西放一起
Lucia: Put the sweet potatoes with these things.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: 为什么我买了两袋红薯
Lucia: Why did I buy two bags of sweet potatoes?
Tasha: 一不一样的
Tasha: They're different.
Alice: 不样的品种
Alice: Different varieties.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Tasha: 这个鸡蛋放哪里呢
Tasha: Where should I put these eggs?
Tasha: 哎呦这个厨房好小呀
Tasha: This kitchen is so small.
Alice: 这这这置物架
Alice: This, this, this shelf.
Alice: 置物架
Alice: The shelf.
Tasha: 可是感觉哎
Tasha: But it feels like...
Tasha: 方罩不太好拿
Tasha: The cover is hard to reach.
Alice: 没事用的时候再拿出来
Alice: No worries, just take it out when you need it.
Lucia: 这个要不就放这个里面
Lucia: How about we put this in here?
Lucia: 跟这些放一起
Lucia: With these things.
Lucia: 然后装就暂时放这袋子里
Lucia: Then temporarily put this in the bag.
Lucia: 那个咖啡放这里面
Lucia: Put the coffee in here.
Alice: 也放里面吧
Alice: Put it in here too.
Alice: 这个没地安置
Alice: There's no place for this.
Alice: 他也放那吧
Alice: Put it there too.
Alice: 感觉他在哪里都不好看
Alice: It looks bad no matter where it is.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake: 就放这了
Jake: Just put it here.
Jake: 啊这两个
Jake: Ah, these two...
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What's up?
Jake: 还要吗
Jake: Do we still need these?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This...
Jake: 就放这吧
Jake: Let's just put it here.
Tasha: 就放这
Tasha: Just put it here.
Lucia: 要一下 要一下也行
Lucia: It's okay to have a little.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Lucia: 这个会坏的这么快吗
Lucia: Does it spoil this quickly?
Alice: 昨天到现在都快24小时
Alice: It's been almost 24 hours since yesterday.
Alice:赶紧给它喝了不得了
Alice: We need to drink it quickly.
Tasha: 因为
Tasha: Because...
Lucia: 咱今天晚上把它喝了要不
Lucia: Why don't we drink it tonight?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha: 嗯，不要再放了
Tasha: Yeah, don't store it anymore.
Jake:行那
Jake: Alright then.
Jake:带劲了
Jake: Exciting.
Jake: 这玻璃隔音确实一般
Jake: This glass's soundproofing isn't great.
Jake: 听的还挺呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: You can still hear everything, hehehe.
Jake: 丢掉了
Jake: Thrown away.
Katrina:  你那个蛋挞皮跟芋泥是怎么弄的芋圆
Katrina: How did you make the tart crust and taro balls?
Alice:荔浦芋头就行
Alice: Lipu taro will do.
Katrina:  买了吗
Katrina: Did you buy it?
Alice:没有没有
Alice: No, no.
Katrina:  我的外送还是快递的
Katrina: Was my order delivered or shipped?
Tasha: 我挑好了
Tasha: I picked it.
Tasha: 呃快递的
Tasha: Uh, it was shipped.
Katrina: 就是你买的是吧
Katrina: So you bought it, right?
Katrina:  蛋挞皮跟那个芋头
Katrina: The tart crust and the taro.
Tasha: 挑好了还没下单呢
Tasha: Picked it but haven't ordered yet.
Katrina:  哦我给你寄一下
Katrina: Oh, I'll send it to you.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 还有展架
Tasha: And the display stand.
Jake: 帮我干一下
Jake: Help me with this.
Alice: 干一下
Alice: Help with this.
Jake:就帮我这个
Jake: Just help me with this.
Tasha: 扒拉一下
Tasha: Give it a nudge.
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 这两个就留在这
Jake: Leave these two here.
Alice:想换个鞋
Alice: I want to change shoes.
Jake: 看看还有什么垃圾我一起扔出去
Jake: See if there's any other trash, I'll throw it out together.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Okay.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Lucia: 这个是什么
Lucia: What is this?
Jake: 这个得是垃圾对
Jake: This must be trash, right?
Tasha: 呦 这个时候应该派出我们的
Tasha: Yo, at this moment we should send out our...
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Jake:哦吼吼吼吼吼
Jake: Oh ho ho ho ho
Lucia: 吼有道理
Lucia: Makes sense
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Right, right, right
Lucia: 先看一下一会把就是该扔的都扔了
Lucia: First, see if there's anything we should throw away
Lucia: 然后再擦
Lucia: And then clean
Katrina:  还好没有买时钟
Katrina: Good thing we didn't buy a clock
Lucia: 还有没有啥要扔的
Lucia: Is there anything else to throw away?
Tasha: 没有买什么
Tasha: Didn't buy what?
Katrina: 时钟
Katrina: A clock
Alice: 有那个厨房
Alice: We have that kitchen...
Jake:开买吧
Jake: Go ahead and buy it
Jake:快递吧快递
Jake: Delivery, delivery
Katrina:  快递
Katrina: Delivery
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah
Alice:就是一个普通的钟就行了
Alice: Just an ordinary clock will do
Katrina: 还有还有就是
Katrina: And also...
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Right, right, right
Lucia: 你透气啊
Lucia: Take a breath, will you?
Katrina:  要挂的吗
Katrina: Do you want a wall clock?
Katrina:  还是白的
Katrina: Or a white one?
Jake: 呃我来买这个就好
Jake: Uh, I'll just buy it
Tasha: 为什么要买时钟
Tasha: Why do we need a clock?
Katrina:  我不知道他这些啊
Katrina: I don't know about these things
Jake: 因为要计时
Jake: Because we need to keep track of time
Jake: 各位3点 3个小时就要听
Jake: Everyone, at 3 o'clock, we need to listen in 3 hours
Tasha: 那个呃
Tasha: That, uh...
Tasha: 盒子
Tasha: The box
Lucia: 啥盒子
Lucia: What box?
Tasha: 就是甜品不同的盒子
Tasha: The boxes for different desserts
Tasha: 对甜品盒
Tasha: Yeah, dessert boxes
Tasha: 行就这么多应该就这行
Tasha: Okay, that's it, should be fine with just these
Jake:好
Jake: Alright
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Wonderful
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 其他的应该收拾的差不多
Lucia: The rest should be pretty much cleaned up
Jake:扔完了是吧
Jake: Finished throwing it away, right?
Jake: 那我出去扔掉
Jake: Then I'll go out and throw it away
Lucia: 这俩袋子
Lucia: These two bags
Lucia: 可以留着就这两天在倒垃圾用
Lucia: We can save them for trash over the next couple of days.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 那个是什么
Jake: What's that?
Lucia: 微传
Lucia: Microtransmitter
Tasha: 保鲜膜
Tasha: Cling film
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one
Lucia: 你说这个吗
Lucia: You mean this one?
Lucia: 呃这个
Lucia: Uh, this one
Alice: 那个鲜花的
Alice: That flower one
Tasha: 营养剂
Tasha: Nutrient
Lucia: 这是花的营养液
Lucia: This is flower nutrient solution
Alice:可以把它扔了吧
Alice: Can we just throw it away?
Alice: 不用也行
Alice: We don't need it anyway.
Katrina:  倒进去要不要
Katrina: Should we pour it in?
Jake: 啊不用了
Jake: Ah, no need.
Lucia: 这个需要用吗
Lucia: Do we need to use this?
Lucia: 可以不用
Lucia: We don't have to.
Tasha: 哦用的话花会活的更久
Tasha: Oh, if we use it, the flowers will last longer.
Katrina:  那往里面倒一点我
Katrina: Then let me pour some in.
Katrina:  我来倒哈哈
Katrina: I'll pour it, haha.
Jake: 那就不用了
Jake: Then we don't need it.
Lucia: 那就随便了
Lucia: Whatever then.
Lucia: 我来倒太懂了
Lucia: I'll pour it, I get it.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 打了起来
Jake: It turned into a fight.
Jake:扎马炮喜欢呵呵
Jake: Zama loves it, hahaha.
Katrina:  打起来打起来
Katrina: Fight, fight!
Jake: 喜欢打起来
Jake: Loves fighting.
Jake: 喜欢
Jake: Loves it.
Jake: 好数据
Jake: Good data.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Katrina:  0点三liters什么意思
Katrina: What does 0.3 liters mean?
Katrina:  呃Rage 0.3升
Katrina: Uh, Rage, 0.3 liters
Jake:l升
Jake: One liter
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh
Lucia: 就是300毫升哎
Lucia: It's 300 milliliters.
Jake:哎这个
Jake: Hey, this
Lucia: 我觉得咱这个应该稀释
Lucia: I think we should dilute this.
Katrina:  每一包用0.3升的水
Katrina: Use 0.3 liters of water for each pack.
Katrina:  这都有3升了
Katrina: This is already 3 liters.
Lucia: 那那肯定够了
Lucia: That should be enough.
Alice: 0.3升对这么浓的吗
Alice: 0.3 liters for something this thick?
Jake:300毫升
Jake: 300 milliliters.
Alice: 他就给了一包哎对哎
Alice: He only gave one pack, right?
Jake: 试一试新买的湿巾纸
Jake: Let's try the new wet wipes.
Katrina:  每包0.3升水是不是
Katrina: Each pack is 0.3 liters, right?
Jake: 嗯这300毫80毫升0.38
Jake: Yeah, this is 300 milliliters... 80 milliliters... 0.38.
Alice: 这么多花
Alice: So many flowers.
Alice: 他才给了一包既然不是
Alice: He only gave one pack, right?
Katrina:  这也不知道谁的水
Katrina: I don't know whose water this is.
Katrina:  用来浇花吧哎
Katrina: Let's use it to water the plants.
Alice: 我刚打开的哦
Alice: I just opened it.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hehehe... Hahahahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈我以为是我早上的呢
Alice: Hahaha, I thought it was mine from the morning.
Jake: 其实是知道的呵呵
Jake: Actually, I knew it. Hehe.
Katrina:  想制造冲突哈哈哈
Katrina: Trying to create some drama. Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 背景音乐来个音效
Jake: Let's add some sound effects to the background music.
Lucia: 嘿Siri
Lucia: Hey, Siri.
Jake:呵呵呵哈哈哈
Jake: Hehehe... Hahaha.
Lucia: 啊让Siri放首歌
Lucia: Ah, ask Siri to play a song.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 啊不用洗洁精吗
Alice: Ah, don't we need dish soap?
Jake: 用用用只是试一下这个
Jake: Yes, yes, just trying this out.
Lucia: 试一下这个厨房纸
Lucia: Try this kitchen paper.
Jake: 对对给他点面子
Jake: Yeah, let's give it a try.
Jake: 买都买了
Jake: We bought it anyway.
Jake: 用他一下
Jake: Let's use it.
Alice: 买都买
Alice: We bought it.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's fine.
Lucia: 等到咱们吃火锅的时候他应该很有用
Lucia: When we have hotpot, it should be very useful.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Jake: 外卖咱还没点了
Jake: We haven't ordered takeout yet.
Katrina:  呃点吧现在有点饿
Katrina: Uh, let's order now, I'm a bit hungry.
Jake: 咱午饭没多久但是可以饿
Jake: We just had lunch not long ago, but it's fine to be hungry.
Katrina:  我感觉我属于那种饱的快
Katrina: I feel like I'm the type who gets full quickly.
Katrina:  饿的也快那种
Katrina: And gets hungry quickly too.
Katrina:  少吃多餐
Katrina: Small, frequent meals.
Lucia: 这是什么呀
Lucia: What is this?
Jake:就是
Jake: It's just...
Alice: 沙球
Alice: Sandball.
Lucia: 是这样玩的吗
Lucia: Is this how you play?
Jake: 呃这个是
Jake: Uh, this is...
Katrina:  这样这样这样这样
Katrina: Like this, like this, like this.
Jake: 这是修硕的
Jake: This is Shure's.
Jake: 小礼品
Jake: Little gift.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake: 这个好像还没有互相送
Jake: It seems we haven't exchanged gifts yet.
Katrina:  没有交换礼物这个环节
Katrina: There's no gift exchange segment.
Jake: 有我忘了
Jake: Oh, I forgot.
Katrina: 啊对啊对
Katrina: Oh, yes, yes.
Jake:第一天我忘了
Jake: I forgot on the first day.
Katrina:  我说还没有到
Katrina: I said it hasn't happened yet.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Alice: 我以为要放在后边呢
Alice: I thought it was scheduled for later.
Jake: 嗯对这个每天都整点小游戏嘛
Jake: Yeah, we have little games every day.
Alice: 把那个叶子给它捞出来
Alice: Scoop out those leaves.
Alice: 要不然它会烂
Alice: Otherwise, they'll rot.
Katrina:  哦我感觉我不太懂这边
Katrina: Oh, I feel like I don't quite get this part.
Jake: 就是各位破冰破的太快了
Jake: You guys broke the ice too quickly.
Jake: 一下就破了
Jake: It broke instantly.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 一下就破了
Lucia: It broke instantly.
Jake: 哈哈哈感觉不用什么礼物
Jake: Hahaha, feels like we don't need gifts.
Lucia: 迅速的熟识了起来
Lucia: We got to know each other quickly.
Jake: 对感觉不用什么礼物
Jake: Yeah, feels like we don't need gifts.
Jake:呵
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 芍药真的好好看哦
Lucia: Peonies are really beautiful.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm.
Katrina:  你看我的压花
Katrina: Look at my pressed flowers.
Jake: 哇这咖啡这么好
Jake: Wow, this coffee is so good.
Jake: 你们谁先选
Jake: Who wants to pick first?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:就是你了
Jake: It's you.
Jake: 选一家
Jake: Pick one.
Lucia: 选个吃的吧
Lucia: Pick something to eat.
Tasha: 就这几家选吗
Tasha: Just these few to choose from?
Jake: 应该不止几家
Jake: It should be more than a few.
Alice: 嗯嗯这个是不是也快到时间了
Alice: Hmm, is this one almost done too?
Alice: 慢
Alice: Slow
Jake: 呃你可以看一下这个还有多少Storage
Jake: 120G是三个小时啊
Jake: 120G is three hours, right?
Jake: 110G三个小时
Jake: 110G is three hours.
Alice: 嗯还有40G  那我吃这个吧
Alice: Hmm, there's 40G left. I'll have this one then.
Jake:ok
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 啥呀
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 私房菜
Tasha: Homemade dishes.
Alice:死亡菜
Alice: Death dishes.
Tasha: 私房菜
Tasha: Homemade dishes.
Alice: 哦私房菜
Alice: Oh, homemade dishes.
Jake: 酸菜炖
Jake: Pickled cabbage stew.
Tasha: 啊我没有说要吃这个菜啊
Tasha: Ah, I didn't say I wanted to eat that.
Jake: 我知道我知道OK
Jake: I know, I know. Okay.
Jake: 红烧土豆   红烧土豆
Jake: Braised potatoes. Braised potatoes.
Jake: 哈哈他叫土豆侠子你知道吗
Jake: Haha, he's called Potato Hero, you know?
Alice: 土豆侠子
Alice: Potato Hero.
Lucia: 所以会吃土豆
Lucia: So he eats potatoes.
Jake: 上来给我看一堆土豆
Jake: He shows me a bunch of potatoes.
Alice: 他喜欢土豆
Alice: He likes potatoes.
Jake: 喜欢吃土豆
Jake: Likes to eat potatoes.
Tasha: 是的只要花298就可以加入我的土门
Tasha: Yes, you just have to spend 298 to join my Potato Clan.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 但是因为这个所以叫土豆侠子吗
Lucia: But is that why he's called Potato Hero?
Jake:天天都可以吃土豆
Jake: He can eat potatoes every day.
Lucia: 啊就是是因为
Lucia: Ah, so it's because...
Lucia: 你是因为喜欢吃土豆
Lucia: You like to eat potatoes?
Lucia: 所以叫土豆侠子的吗
Lucia: So you're called Potato Hero?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 怎么觉得听起来有点像
Lucia: Why does it sound like...
Lucia: 一个编出来的理由
Lucia: A made-up reason.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 门店热销土豆红烧肉盖饭就这个吧
Jake: The store's best-selling braised pork with potatoes rice bowl. Let's go with that.
Tasha: 啊每个人吃自己的饭是吗
Tasha: Ah, everyone eats their own meal, right?
Tasha: 哦也可以哦
Tasha: Oh, that's fine too.
Jake: 你说点这种大菜是吧
Jake: So you want to order a big dish, right?
Tasha: 哦我以为是点大菜
Tasha: Oh, I thought we were ordering a big dish.
Jake: 哦那也行啊点大菜
Jake: Oh, that works too, let's get a big dish.
Jake: 那每人点一个吧
Jake: How about everyone orders one dish?
Tasha: 每人点一个
Tasha: Everyone orders one dish?
Tasha: 嗯四个女生
Tasha: Hmm, four girls...
Tasha: 我感觉吃两到三个菜就差不多了
Tasha: I think two or three dishes should be enough.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 对嗯差不多
Lucia: Yeah, that sounds about right.
Jake: 那你先点一个
Jake: You go ahead and order one first.
Jake: 你先点个土豆吧
Jake: You order a potato dish first.
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No.
Jake:啊你找一个土豆店不点土豆
Jake: Huh, you come to a potato place and don't order potatoes?
Lucia: 点一个里面带土豆的菜
Lucia: Order a dish with potatoes in it.
Katrina:  点那种什么肉蟹煲
Katrina: Order something like a crab pot.
Katrina:  什么什么煲里面很多土豆
Katrina: Those kinds of pots have a lot of potatoes.
Katrina:  就是他根本就没有那么多肉
Katrina: They barely have any meat in them.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 哇感觉好好吃
Tasha: Wow, it sounds so delicious.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice: 哪个
Alice: Which one?
Jake:想象出来的肉蟹煲
Jake: The imagined crab pot.
Jake: 土豆包
Jake: Potato pot.
Alice:吓我一跳
Alice: You scared me.
Tasha: 记得备注一下不要香菜
Tasha: Remember to note no cilantro.
Alice:你说啥呀
Alice: What did you say?
Tasha: 不要啥菜啊
Tasha: No cilantro.
Alice: 你点的啥
Alice: What did you order?
Alice: 我点了个水煮肉
Alice: I ordered boiled meat.
Jake: 哎对
Jake: Oh, right.
Jake: 你们晚上是propose的什么活动来着
Jake: What activity did you propose for tonight?
Tasha: propose了
Tasha: Propose.
Jake: 你们是逛超市的时候
Jake: When you guys were shopping at the supermarket.
Jake: propose的两个什么
Jake: What were the two things you proposed?
Jake: 要做菜做甜点
Jake: Cooking dishes and making desserts.
Jake: 做半个小时甜点
Jake: Making desserts for half an hour.
Tasha: 可以啊
Tasha: Sounds good.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 你为啥不点土豆啊
Alice: Why didn't you order potatoes?
Alice: 我给你点上吧
Alice: Let me order it for you.
Alice: 哈哈排骨土豆炖豆角
Alice: Haha, ribs with potatoes and beans.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice: 还有啥土豆啊
Alice: What other potatoes?
Tasha: 都可以都可以
Tasha: Anything is fine.
Alice: 排骨土豆
Alice: Pork ribs with potatoes.
Tasha: 要不要吃回锅肉
Tasha: How about twice-cooked pork?
Alice: 那你不要你的土豆了
Alice: Then you don't want your potatoes?
Tasha: 可以不要
Tasha: It's okay not to have them.
Tasha: 哈哈回锅肉
Tasha: Haha, twice-cooked pork.
Tasha: 锅包肉锅包肉
Tasha: Sweet and sour pork!
Tasha: 番茄牛腩
Tasha: Tomato beef brisket.
Jake: 白板担当
Jake: The whiteboard person.
Tasha: 嗯都可以
Tasha: Yeah, anything is fine.
Alice: 这个或者
Alice: This one or...
Jake:留的
Jake: Reserved.
Alice: 哎你刚说哪个
Alice: Hey, which one did you just say?
Tasha: 锅包肉回锅肉
Tasha: Sweet and sour pork, twice-cooked pork.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:要两种肉
Jake: Want two kinds of meat.
Alice:麻辣的孜然的
Alice: Spicy cumin.
Alice: 这是酸辣的
Alice: This one is sour and spicy.
Katrina:  是我们四个
Katrina: It's the four of us.
Katrina:  还带他一起吗
Katrina: Are we taking him along?
Lucia: 对我们一起四个菜
Lucia: Yeah, the four of us together, four dishes.
Katrina:  三荤一素
Katrina: Three meat, one veggie.
Tasha: 三
Tasha: Three.
Tasha: 哦有素菜吗
Tasha: Oh, is there a veggie dish?
Tasha: 我们没有点过素菜
Tasha: We haven't ordered a veggie dish.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Alice: 你俩想吃哪个你点两个啊
Alice: Which one do you two want? You pick two.
Tasha:哦 不 我要
Tasha: Oh, no, I want...
Lucia: 或者或者或者番茄牛腩
Lucia: Or, or, or tomato beef brisket.
Lucia: 里面有番茄
Lucia: It has tomatoes.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 姑且算是半个素菜
Lucia: Let's count it as half a veggie dish.
Lucia: 那那素菜
Lucia: Then, the veggie dish...
Tasha: 素菜里面要一个手撕包菜
Tasha: For the veggie dish, let's have hand-torn cabbage.
Tasha: 或者要一个酸辣土豆丝
Tasha: Or spicy shredded potatoes.
Alice: 哈哈可以土豆在这等着呢啊
Alice: Haha, the potatoes are waiting here.
Tasha: 还差个汤
Tasha: We're still missing a soup.
Tasha: 现在就开始煮吧
Tasha: Let's start cooking now.
Tasha: 哈哈现在开始煮汤
Tasha: Haha, let's start making the soup now.
Alice: 今天晚上就喝吧
Alice: Let's drink it tonight.
Alice:是吧
Alice: Right?
Tasha: 是今天晚上开始做汤吗
Tasha: Are we making the soup tonight?
Tasha: 反正吃家常菜吗
Tasha: Anyway, we're having homemade food, right?
Jake: 可以啊你说等的时候做汤吗
Jake: Sure, are you saying make the soup while we wait?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 他要送多久啊
Jake: How long will it take?
Jake: 40分钟
Jake: 40 minutes.
Alice:可能吧
Alice: Maybe.
Katrina:  送密封袋
Katrina: Delivering the sealed bags.
Tasha: 现在是7点半
Tasha: It's 7:30 now.
Jake:密封哦
Jake: Sealed, okay.
Katrina:  那我试验一下
Katrina: Let me test it.
Tasha: 那我现在开始在做甜品的话
Tasha: If I start making the dessert now,
Tasha: 8点半还能开会哦
Tasha: We can still have a meeting at 8:30.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  今天晚上开会吗
Katrina: Are we having a meeting tonight?
Alice: 点这个吧
Alice: Tap this.
Jake:她要开会
Jake: She has a meeting.
Alice: 我不太想吃猪
Alice: I don't really want to eat pork.
Alice: 可以吗
Alice: Is that okay?
Tasha: 可以啊可以
Tasha: Sure, sure.
Jake: 他自己要开会
Jake: She has her own meeting.
Katrina:  我可能有点事
Katrina: I might have something to do.
Jake:他学校
Jake: It's her school.
Alice: 那我们开始做吧
Alice: Let's start then.
Jake:ok
Jake: Ok.
Alice: 你让他点
Alice: Let him choose.
Katrina:  摘两片芍药花瓣
Katrina: Pick two peony petals.
Tasha: 神圣的交接仪
Tasha: The sacred handover ceremony.
Alice: 来吧我们开始吧
Alice: Come on, let's start.
Tasha: 好我们开始吧
Tasha: Okay, let's start.
Alice: 我们几个人做汤的话需要
Alice: If we're making soup, we need a few people.
Tasha: 你需要一个配手
Tasha: You need a helper.
Tasha: 我需要一个配手
Tasha: I need a helper.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Right?
Alice:我不需要哦
Alice: I don't need one.
Alice: 我自己给自己打下手
Alice: I'm helping myself out.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  好 需要我帮忙吗
Katrina: Alright, do you need my help?
Alice: 我们需要做多少量呢
Alice: How much do we need to make?
Tasha: 嗯一人一碗的量就行
Tasha: Hmm, just enough for one bowl per person.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice:一人一碗是
Alice: One bowl per person is...
Alice: 哎我不知道大家的饭量
Alice: Uh, I don't know how much everyone eats.
Alice: 嗯对汤就汤多
Alice: Hmm, for soup, just make more.
Lucia: 汤嘛
Lucia: Soup?
Alice:对 就汤多
Alice: Yeah, just more soup.
Alice: 多一点应该叶没事
Alice: A bit more should be fine.
Lucia:这个多少应该
Lucia: How much should this be?
Alice: 那我把我戒指取下来
Alice: Then I'll take off my ring.
Alice: 不行都放不掉
Alice: No, it won't come off.
Lucia: 需要我做什么呢
Lucia: What do you need me to do?
Lucia: 哈哈哈等待指派中
Lucia: Hahaha, waiting for instructions.
Tasha: 等一下
Tasha: Wait a second.
Jake:我问一下谢明珠来不来
Jake: I'll ask if Xie Mingzhu is coming.
Jake: 他有可能来
Jake: He might come.
Jake: 来的话就多加一个人
Jake: If he comes, we'll add one more person.
Tasha: 哎米饭是不是没点
Tasha: Hey, did we order the rice?
Tasha: 谁来谢冰珠
Tasha: Who's coming, Xie Bingzhu?
Tasha: 米饭掉了吗
Tasha: Did the rice get ordered?
Jake: 就是那个
Jake: It's that one.
Jake: 没有没点
Jake: No, we didn't order.
Tasha: 为什么不点米饭
Tasha: Why didn't you order rice?
Jake: 因为我还没下单呢
Jake: Because I haven't placed the order yet.
Tasha: 哦那就行
Tasha: Oh, that's fine then.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehe.
Alice: 那我现在开始吧
Alice: Then I'll start now.
Jake:害怕
Jake: Scared.
Tasha: 好的你先开始
Tasha: Okay, you start first.
Jake:害怕
Jake: Scared.
Lucia: 我要不简单的
Lucia: I want something simple.
Lucia: 做饭的话我要不要换个洞
Lucia: If I cook, should I change the hole?
Lucia: 我能把它先摘下来一下吗
Lucia: Can I take it off first?
Lucia: 我换个衣服
Lucia: I'll change clothes.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 这样好做一点
Lucia: This way it's easier.
Jake:唉，好行
Jake: Yeah, okay, fine.
Lucia: 不用关吧
Lucia: No need to turn it off, right?
Jake:你就放在这里对对对嗯嗯
Jake: Just put it here, yeah, yeah, right.
Lucia: 我在这里放一下吧
Lucia: I'll put it here for now.
Lucia: 然后一会再下去
Lucia: Then we'll move it later.
Alice: 哎呀冻得梆梆硬
Alice: Oh my, it's frozen rock solid.
Alice: 放上边吧
Alice: Put it on top.
Lucia: 我还以为我一直连着电线呢
Lucia: I thought I was still plugged in.
Lucia: 居然没有
Lucia: But apparently not.
Jake: 好那就趁机充个电
Jake: Well, let's take the chance to charge it.
Lucia: 哎有道理
Lucia: Ah, good idea.
Lucia: 先把它连上
Lucia: Let's connect it first.
Alice: 怎么会把它放在这里面呢
Alice: Why did we put it in here?
Alice: 我们是买了两个金针菇还是一个呀
Alice: Did we buy two enoki mushrooms or just one?
Tasha: 一个好像
Tasha: Just one, I think.
Alice:一个
Alice: Just one.
Tasha: 一袋
Tasha: One bag.
Alice:一个吗
Alice: Just one?
Alice: 嗯是呢
Alice: Yeah, seems so.
Alice: 算了就这样吧
Alice: Whatever, let's leave it.
Alice: 我怎么会把
Alice: How did I...
Alice: 皮蛋放冷冻呢
Alice: Put the century egg in the freezer?
小汾：花好香啊
Katrina: The flowers smell so nice.
Katrina:  到底是哪种花香
Katrina: What kind of flowers are they?
Alice: 开始吧
Alice: Let's start.
Alice: 找一下盆
Alice: Let's find a basin.
Alice: 大刀
Alice: A big knife.
Alice: 锅在哪
Alice: Where's the pot?
Alice: 还要自己刷这个
Alice: I have to wash this myself?
Alice: 掉出来了掉出来了
Alice: It's falling out, it's falling out.
Tasha: 哎呀
Tasha: Oh no.
Alice: 就这个吧
Alice: Let's use this one.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Alice: 定个咣当的
Alice: It's making a loud noise.
Jake: 我去一把大菜刀
Jake: I'll go get a big knife.
Jake: 这菜刀是不是不够
Jake: Is this knife not enough?
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Jake: 这菜刀是不是不够锋利呀
Jake: Is this knife not sharp enough?
Alice: 切个白菜无所谓
Alice: Cutting some cabbage is no big deal.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 不太想让我的戒指沾水
Alice: I don't really want my ring to get wet.
Alice: 说实话我要给它去下来了
Alice: Honestly, I'm going to take it off.
Alice: 给你个神圣的职责照看他一下
Alice: I'm giving you the sacred duty of looking after it.
Alice: 这锅几百年没刷了
Alice: This pot hasn't been scrubbed in centuries.
Katrina:  这是干啥的
Katrina: What's this for?
Alice: 说实话这个锅没有很大
Alice: Honestly, this pot isn't that big.
Alice: 噔噔
Alice: Ta-da.
Alice: 菜板
Alice: Cutting board.
Alice: 这个也不能沾水
Alice: This can't get wet either.
Alice: 你帮我去掉一下
Alice: Can you help me remove it?
Tasha: 是这样吗
Tasha: Like this?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Jake: 你在切啥
Jake: What are you chopping?
Tasha: 加三次糖
Tasha: Add sugar three times.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Tasha: 不记得了
Tasha: Can't remember.
Tasha: 呃不是不
Tasha: Uh, no.
Tasha: 记得了具体的配方
Tasha: I remember the exact recipe.
Alice: 我先把你这个放一边了啊
Alice: I'll put this aside for now.
Tasha: 找蛋戳
Tasha: Look for the egg pricker.
Tasha: 这个这个心OK
Tasha: This, this heart is okay.
Tasha: 就这样
Tasha: Just like this.
Tasha: 然后烤箱温度记一下子
Tasha: Then note the oven temperature.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Ta-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Tasha: can you help me
Tasha: Can you help me?
Jake: yes
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: yes
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 呃我的无菌手套呢
Tasha: Uh, where are my sterile gloves?
Tasha: 被谁呢拿到哪里去了
Tasha: Who took them and where?
Jake: 你的什么
Jake: Your what?
Tasha: 哦在这里
Tasha: Oh, here they are.
Tasha: police and me take this
Tasha: Police and me take this.
Alice: 松花蛋在哪里
Alice: Where are the century eggs?
Jake: 松花蛋OK
Jake: Century eggs, okay.
Tasha: 松花蛋在这里在在
Tasha: Century eggs are here, here.
Alice: 哦ok
Alice: Oh, okay.
Jake:帮你
Jake: Helping you.
Katrina: 有啥要要我帮忙的不
Katrina: Is there anything you need help with?
Katrina:  嗯i can我已经free了
Katrina: Hmm, I can help. I'm free now.
Jake:好滴
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  我看看我这压花
Katrina: Let me check my pressing flowers.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  这两天能压出什么东西
Katrina: What can I press out in these two days?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  先尝试一个
Katrina: Let's try one first.
Jake: 你要你你你是你你
Jake: You, you, you...
Katrina:  我已经压了一个
Katrina: I've already pressed one.
Jake: 你要在地上压还是最好有个桌子还是
Jake: Do you want to press it on the floor or is it better to have a table?
Katrina:  不是我那个板
Katrina: No, it's my board.
Katrina:  就是那个压花板
Katrina: The flower pressing board.
Katrina:  我已经放了几片花瓣进去了
Katrina: I've already put some petals in.
Katrina:  不知道压出来什么效果
Katrina: I don't know what the result will be.
Katrina:  它不是也要两三天吗
Katrina: Doesn't it take two to three days?
Jake: 哦哦就就是你你一直在地上压这个是不是
Jake: Oh, so you've been pressing this on the floor all the time?
Jake: 嗯伤腰啊呵呵
Jake: Hmm, it's bad for your back, haha.
Katrina:  没事年轻的
Katrina: It's okay, I'm young.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:ok哈哈哈好嘞
Jake: Okay, hahaha, alright.
Tasha: 他在说你
Tasha: He's talking about you.
Jake: 对确实
Jake: Yeah, indeed.
Katrina:  今天下午坐地上插了花然后也压了
Katrina: This afternoon I sat on the floor arranging flowers and pressing them.
Jake: 哎你要哪个
Jake: Hey, which one do you want?
Tasha: 哦我有我其实
Tasha: Oh, I have, actually...
Tasha: 好吧那你不带也行
Tasha: Well, you don't have to bring it.
Jake:我要
Jake: I want it.
Tasha: 你不用了
Tasha: You don't need it anymore.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 哎呦哎好求助一下
Tasha: Oh, wait, help me out.
Jake:好你你看我我能干这个
Jake: Okay, look, I can do this.
Jake: 对来吧来吧来吧
Jake: Yes, come on, come on, come on.
Tasha: 我一开始是想让你也带一双的
Tasha: At first, I wanted you to bring a pair too.
Jake: 哦我以为你帮我
Jake: Oh, I thought you were helping me.
Jake: 你让我稍微
Jake: You let me...
Alice: 可以了thank you
Alice: That's enough, thank you.
Alice: 你可真难出来呀兄弟
Alice: You really are hard to get out, brother.
Tasha: 我刚刚的那个大的那个盆呢
Tasha: Where's that big bowl I just had?
Alice:盆
Alice: Bowl?
Tasha: 大的那个盆
Tasha: The big one.
Alice: 我给你搁那了
Alice: I put it over there for you.
Alice: 是那个吧
Alice: Is it that one?
Tasha: 哦我刀呢
Tasha: Oh, where's my knife?
Alice: 没洗呢
Alice: It's not washed yet.
Tasha: 天呐这
Tasha: Oh my god, this...
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Tasha: 餐巾纸
Tasha: Napkins.
Jake: 有得等一下我先
Jake: Hold on a sec, let me...
Alice: give me
Alice: Give me.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:ok
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 我突然找不见自己房间的灯了
Lucia: I suddenly can't find the light in my room.
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Alice:可还行
Alice: That's okay.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Alice: 我觉得这个
Alice: I think this...
Jake: 什么东西
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 大成功
Jake: Big success!
Jake:我是听到了是什么
Jake: I heard what it was.
Katrina:  啊刚刚打鸡蛋成功哈哈
Katrina: Ah, I successfully cracked the egg, haha.
Jake: 打鸡蛋打成功
Jake: You successfully cracked the egg.
Katrina:  这可以放心
Katrina: This is reassuring.
Katrina:  主要是因为失败了好几次哈哈
Katrina: Mainly because I failed several times before, haha.
Jake: 嗯OK
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Jake: 打鸡蛋大成功
Jake: Cracking the egg was a big success.
Lucia: 哎这个不行这个这个也得抹一下
Lucia: Hey, this one doesn't work, this one also needs a wipe.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina: 棒棒
Katrina: Awesome!
Alice: 现在刚好放清一下
Alice: Now it's just right to clear up a bit.
Lucia: 额现在是几点
Lucia: Uh, what time is it now?
Lucia:我手上好像有点蛋清姐妹看一下
Lucia: I think I have some egg whites on my hand, can you check, sis?
Katrina:  57
Katrina: 57.
Lucia:67
Lucia: 67.
Katrina:  67
Katrina: 67.
Lucia: 呃07哈哈
Lucia: Uh, 07, haha.
Lucia:sorry
Lucia: Sorry.